[Music]
listening don't think for six months no
thinking no thinking no valuing how many
views how many followers no numbers no
thinking make make make make make every
little awesome creative thing running
through your beautiful brain make make
make got it you got your perspective it
is tea time as they call it here in New
Jersey April 1st April Fool's Day but no
one [ __ ] fooling around here today
we've got a ton of guests I'm super
fired up the show has built enormous
amendment momentum we are now into day
eight of this format we are punching
Corona in the [ __ ] throat I just want
to give a big shout out to all the prior
callers I've really enjoyed it and a
huge shout out to the Twitter community
I'm honestly going you know because I
need so much action during the two hours
I'm so zoned in everybody who's on
Twitter is bringing me so much value so
if you're tweeting especially you're
taking a screenshot of the show and and
sharing it on Twitter with a link the
Facebook link would mean the world to me
it is in my it isn't my Instagram
profile actually Team Gary B if you're
watching right now please change my my
URL right now on Twitter to the T live
stream on facebook URL so that people
who are watching right now that go to
Twitter can copy the URL from them
hashtag T with Gary B if you're sharing
on Twitter and as we've been doing the
whole time the last couple days very
intensely if you're looking for a follow
for me on Twitter or some more exposure
I am retweeting and following all along
as people share the show just like
Maddie just did and Amon Kumar he gets a
little bit of a like actually mom you're
gonna follow I am her 28th follower as
you chill in my favorite place New Delhi
India that's right Dustin that is my
favorite place let's get right into the
show then how are you
all right super well my friend where you
from I live east
I grew up in Maine actually love it so I
can answer for you brother no it is here
yeah oh I've been following you for a
while and and I really appreciate
everything you do as London Thank You
first Thank You Ben Europe I actually
came and saw you live in 2015 in
Birmingham Alabama and that really set
the stage for me to even believe that
social media was a thing that anybody
did I was like something my sister would
do I was like I totally get it
I told you so now really I've only
really been all in on it for about six
months and and mostly just posting
photos and everything like that and I
just my question that I sent in was how
do I not feel like an ass clown you know
whatever I start posting whenever and
close myself I always feel really
contrived yeah I think I think I think
it comes down to not valuing other
people's opinions more than your own
happiness and opportunity the fact that
there are so many millions of people
right now that are aware that lives and
podcasts and blogs and tick-tocks
can change the course of their lives
unlike you 315 the Birmingham talk there
are plenty of people who just don't even
realize that you're that you can go from
zero to two hundred thousand and
happiness you know can literally go from
80,000 and unhappy to two hundred
thousand or happy or even my favorite
one from three hundred thirteen thousand
a year in revenue for themselves job or
business and on end unhappy to 196 and
super happy right they both work right
happy is the common bond not how much
you take home there's a millions of
people that don't even know that to be
true
if you go and make content on LinkedIn
YouTube Facebook Instagram what breaks
my heart is more your set the millions
the hundreds of millions tens of
millions minimally that do know that
that can happen but value other people's
random comments over living their best
[ __ ] life it makes me it drives me
then it drives me I have a huge thirst
for giving back a huge just need to
bring value and conversate and build
community and lead and and this is what
I've chose to talk about there's so many
things I could be doing I'm sure as a
human talking about leading on it is
that we are living in the greatest era
of opportunity in the history of mankind
it is called the Internet you are
sitting in a [ __ ] car right now and
I'm sitting in New Jersey we are talking
to each other and 10,000 people are
watching what are you two like right
like could you imagine no brother listen
to me like you have to go into a deep
place and I'm not joking when I say this
whether it's 50 therapy sessions whether
it's meditation whether it's playing me
on repeat whether it's working out
whether it's writing things down whether
it's having a very difficult
conversation with your mother father
sister like that you know or with
yourself you have to figure out how to
put zero value in other people's
opinions over your happiness that
doesn't mean don't listen to people I
listen to every comment I you know I
take feedback but the thought of not
feeling comfortable in my own skin
because somebody might say that you're
full of [ __ ] or you're not smart or you
don't know what you're talking about I'm
trying to eliminate that we are the
world is stuck in high school well yeah
I mean it's the comments from high
school that replay in your head of like
some exactly and and like I know that I
literally anything and
like it's not have you started have you
started producing content on LinkedIn um
not really I've been honestly just
focused on the buck ad with Instagram
Instagram I'm telling you right now
today today post a either a video or
written post about architecture or
building on LinkedIn the link didn't b2b
scenario it LinkedIn is like acting like
Facebook in 2012 you could have 0
followers you don't even have to have a
LinkedIn account as we sit here today
you go and sign up for one you go and
post cuz now you can do that in LinkedIn
unlike unlike five years ago and you
literally post something a blueprint and
and you know a picture of a blueprint
and and write about it I don't give a
[ __ ]
talk talk to them as if you were talking
to a friend that was interested in what
you had to say you will be blown away
about what's going on in there yeah and
I would argue will lead to more business
opportunities than Instagram within the
first month okay
so double down on LinkedIn LinkedIn all
the way go hard pictures of blueprints
write stories or thoughts or make a
video and and really go deep inside
yourself and be like why the [ __ ] would
I give a [ __ ] like to me here's the
thing that helps me when somebody writes
something negative
I feel compassion and sympathy for them
not that they have power over me for
somebody to take the time if their life
is so shitty that they're watching you
and then saying you suck they they're
hurting inside just like police and
[ __ ] high school they're hurting this
side yeah such you got to get over I
give you over myself you got to get over
yourself you got to get over to yourself
in a very interesting way I like that
you said that you got to get over the
facade or the way you've tried to paint
yourself to the world right because
because vulnerability is a very powerful
ingredient in being able to put yourself
out there
I was almost did cause morning
[ __ ] um I'm just I'm losing him I'm
sorry no where no yeah little bit better
go ahead so what I typically do is you
know put on this fake persona that isn't
actually Who I am I love you for having
the strength to say that right now in
this show I'm for that
that means that it's good and that means
your [ __ ] moments away cuz you
[ __ ] you could post for next [ __ ]
you or not have this many people watch
so good news like now just start telling
you know what I mean you're set like the
fact that you can say that on the show
right now means you're inches away from
going there you know yeah but then you
ain't you said yesterday you know the
thing that you're best at being is Gary
Vee I was like that's my [ __ ] problem
right there right you're not best up
being Ben Strout the reference crowd
yeah listen listen you're one post away
you're one push tonight make one video
and say you can do it in one [ __ ]
fall swoop be like here's the real main
they'll change your life I promise you
95% of your inner circle is gonna
message you on facebook or on text you
and be like I'm so proud of you because
what nobody realizes when they're the
fake version of themselves is that
everybody already knows that's the fake
version of you a hundred percent your
true of my friends who are watching
right now you're not tricking anybody
you're [ __ ] not tricking anybody
people here in our circle ready now all
right Ben love you pal I wish you girls
keep going good start then put some fire
got him proud of him he's moments away
good job Luke
sella nice little setup you got there
you get a retweet and a follow on your
hundred twenty second fella
any freed good morning you're getting a
follow two in north carolina any are you
on wine text if you drink wine all right
Sam great awesome I just wanted to say
thank you for taking the time to talk to
me man you know hold of you the last
couple days have been honestly kind of
surreal that a lot going on and kind of
lost track and not sure where to go from
here so my last question or not my last
question my question is um so I from
watching you you kind of remind me of my
father with how headstrong you are and
your motivation just doesn't stop man
you're always going to you I don't know
how that you and gratitude gratitude and
ambition okay when you're grateful when
you're grateful for what you've got
versus dwelling or what you don't have
it actually gives you energy that's
always been my biggest problem because I
mean my dad is extremely successful so I
never was born with out what I wanted
you know not in a rude way you know no
you're saying I'm proud of you for
saying that it's actually hard to say
that so I'm proud of you keep going so
that whole motivation thing of well I've
already got it so you know it's hard
it's hard to be hungry when you that
yeah but the key is for you not to turn
that a lot of kids in your spot right
now are turning that into anger towards
their parents instead of taking on the
accountability that they didn't have to
take the money yeah because that we do
battle a lot me and my mom my dad and we
do battle a ton you battle about and how
does the battle go down what's the
cliche battle well I got a few other
bike I have a couple mental issues going
on so a little bit ADHD depression
anxiety insomnia ones like that yeah a
little bit of extra issues you know I
respect that
yeah so it's you know just [ __ ] that I'm
dealing with of course ended up causing
problems you know cause problems with
the girl and cause problems at home and
stuff like that extra issues that end up
making everybody else a little more
tense and so I guess what I'm trying to
get is how do I get that motivation to
get that hunger to go figure out
something to do when everybody else kind
of ticked off and you're kind of trying
to make things less tough you know
I mean lost the job I've been trying to
get for years do this coronavirus thing
now where do I go now where you go now
is we need to take a big big step back
and really like I think what we need to
frame up is happiness you know like I
think unfortunately like many people
people get caught up in financial
success yeah big time bro Sam it cannot
be the North Star it can't be the North
Star you've got a you've got a probably
how old are you boy dream you know
reframing what you've been thinking
probably for 18 years you know you know
and probably 23 years subconsciously is
difficult but you know to me I don't
want you just checking the box or you
know or just like appeasing I think the
thing that you need to spend a lot of
time on is thinking about what genuinely
would make you happy you know and I and
I you know and I think that you know you
can't look at the world through your
parents eyes society's eyes your girl's
eyes a therapist's eyes you've got to
really look through the world through
your eyes and then be strong enough to
over communicate I think you need to
there's when you when one goes through
that many things anger and dwelling and
and being sad about it manifests and it
becomes momentum when one can start
looking at gratitude like think I'm
alive they got even have a life when
people can go to like thank God I'm 23
and I have 80 more years to figure this
out I can figure this out a 33 and have
a [ __ ] unbelievable life all of a
sudden the pressure figuring it out
right now goes away right when when one
says you know whether your parents say
this or not and obviously I've seen both
versions whether you need to make a lot
of money or be successful
somebody can stand on their own two feet
at forty five thousand a year you just
have to have the humility to rent a
shitty apartment right
I have a beatin sorry I didn't mean it
no no you're not interrupting please
I think coolest thing about my parents
is even though with all the success that
he's had he's never pushed it on us
- you gotta be just as successful as me
you gotta do this awesome I want you to
do what you want to do that makes you
happy and that's huge brother beautiful
do you believe do you believe him yeah
do you know how lucky 15 to go to
boarding school and halfway across the
country because he wanted to yeah I mean
it's he's there it's just I feel like I
don't know one let's not give it back
yeah that's good that's good that you
understand that so what what you like I
need to figure out what your ideology is
see the people you know to me you know I
think a lot about like people's religion
like my religion is the Jets right like
the one place that I am NOT rational
this is silly but true I see it I see it
you know is the Jets I am not thinking
rationally at a Jets game I physically
want to punch a Dolphins fan only 10
years ago
I like pumped a 12 year old wearing a
Brady Jersey literally checked him into
cocky terms into offense this is things
I've done I've rehearsed old men out of
the stadium I get into fights like the
people with the coats and the stands
come in my section almost all the time
I'm completely inappropriate
I have no conscious I'm I'm not myself
now a lot of people are like that about
religion a lot of people a lot of people
especially now are like that about
politics there is there is no rational
conversation with me about Patriot fans
about Pittsburgh fans about dolphins
like like you know and so I understand
having a chapter of my brain that is so
ideological so emotional so irrational
that I can't navigate through that calm
place where I do in business in life in
politics and religion and family like I
can do that I need to figure out what
your ideology is that's beating you up
you're beating yourself up your entire
tone and demeanor is you're [ __ ] on
yourself when you don't need to right
yeah you don't need to we need to figure
out whose opinions you value outside
affirmation did you grow up the kind of
kid that like gave a [ __ ] about what
other kids in high school thought about
you like or an or you know more recently
I said way too much I was grieving what
you said and I still think about that
[ __ ] I was relating myself to the last
dude you were talking about doing the
fake me man I've been doing that since
middle school yeah I mean so it's just
stuffy who's the fake you and who's the
real you that give me give me give me a
little something let's play with him
five seconds there's the fake give me a
fake you couple bullets and give me the
real you couple bullets fake me is
probably really quiet sitting at the bar
not doing much not talking too many
people a kind of a bit of an introvert
you know always been that I guess that
stem from high school not really wanting
to like not being able yourself out
there yeah just know like this I'm
terrified right now just way too many
people I'm proud of you I appreciate it
so it's fake you yeah that's fake me
Rumi I love talking to people I want to
be around I mean that pretty much what
you described being at a football game
is me at a hockey game when we're
playing as stupid penguins you know
have you have you thought about starting
a lightning podcast no never thought of
that
have I ever meet have you ever made
lightning content for an Instagram
account or something I've never really
been much of a social media person one
time I really started this thing on
social media was when Trump was getting
elected and actually gonna watch it for
it and so I said yeah I get it
yeah I'm interesting I've been playing
hockey for about 20 years now so my
intuition seeing this show many times
before the interest guide you into the
light yeah mm-hmm I've seen a lot a lot
of people struggling with a lot of stuff
and Star Trek or garage saleing or the
Tampa Bay Lightning or you know has
taken them into a place you know
one hot take is I think you should start
a media empire your little own media
empire around hockey and temp a
lightning culture you know all upset let
me explain help works out you start this
tick tock account which is one of the
places I'd go immediately you start this
is the RAM account you know you start
you start a podcast you call it
lightning Sam right or some some clever
name right bro you will find your 11
hardcore laning fans in five minutes all
of a sudden those are the guys and gals
you're going to the bar with those are
guys than guys you're meeting at the
parking lot
those are the guys and gals you're
meeting up on zoom in three in three
weeks in three weeks by using the right
hashtags by writing the right post about
the goalie by reminiscing about the
Stanley Cup run three weeks you've got
nine new friends who [ __ ] love the
thing you love them oh I can talk Jets
football in my jet strapped with my
friends and family 24 hours a day yeah I
think you're great loves is what's gonna
pull you out okay yeah that was what I
found with my job my job that I just got
and I love beer hey who doesn't right
and I had gotten into a brewery
it was just rough work cleaning kegs and
you know loved it I loved it man
it was I hated serving tables that god I
hated being a server and me listen to me
yeah lighting do it I think that's an
awesome idea I've honestly been thinking
about the other podcasts or something I
just didn't know if anybody want to
listen my [ __ ] you know definitely
there's a there's definitely this tiny
incredibly passionate group of lightning
fans that 100% want to yeah I mean I
guess what else you DMing on Instagram
now former players from the Stanley Cup
team 14 of them want to be on the
podcast because you know this hockey
players don't get that at that like that
that's true a third line right winger on
the [ __ ] chip on that team is not
[ __ ] known
but you know who he is yeah I know he
step on my toe is from 1994 Rangers life
you know what I mean mm-hmm
okay no Doug wait is I know Tony Granato
I know my gardener I know my Rangers
that maybe a lot of people would have
known from my era so punch line is your
passion we'll pull you the [ __ ] out your
passion we'll pull you out I'm telling
you go all in
create a Twitter a tick-tock an
Instagram and start a YouTube podcast
thing and just [ __ ] go I'm sure you
have one or two friends that like the
lightning as well right yeah totally I
mean just happen
good just have them on the [ __ ] first
show what's your favorite lightning
story who you know what was your
favorite what's the when's the did you
ever cry what was the worst moment best
moment when we come back what do you
think about this seat like just [ __ ]
go just get immersed in making content
about the Lightning go find videos on
YouTube clip them post on your Instagram
write something I remember this play I
was 13 I [ __ ] punched a hole in the
wall like whatever okay just immerse
yourself in your passion because if you
make 65 thousand a year selling hoodies
and having appearance fees doing that
you'll be the happiest [ __ ] boy on
earth that means I might wanna do do do
it Sam I love you brother good luck man
thank you again
you're welcome in keep watching Sam keep
keep listening to the positivity in the
practicality let me pump in your [ __ ]
ears from a couple years here I'll
[ __ ] pull you out brother I promise
about it thank you Gary welcome bro
getting deep here on our tea with Gary B
Mara how are you hi Gary how are you oh
we're at the huge and from Brooklyn New
York I'm a huge fan
I'm probably the only Pakistani American
mom who's a WWE fan that go ever meet I
wanted to ask you a question I'm a
little bit background about me I was a
stay-at-home mom for a bunch of years um
I started my own blog about couponing
and how to save money more to come home
every mom was learning how to save money
and run how to physically you know share
chases and and baby clothes for she I
did that for a couple of years I worked
full-time for a couple of years my kids
are a little bit older now and I
accidentally started a business laughter
so my uncle went um for the pilgrimage
to Mecca to Hajj and when he did that
for a gifts that had one came back was I
gave him a flower garland and this is
like an old-school Pakistani tradition
and I made these Garland's for him and
can you still hear me
I sure can I'm captivated by the story
keep doing it I love you I love that
heritage Nisha's that can be more broad
than people realize so I kind of know
where you're going so I'm just listening
yes so he looked around to see where I
could buy Garland's from I didn't I
couldn't find anyone in New York like I
found one person all the way in Queens I
didn't have time to go all the way over
there
my uncle was like I'll buy a couple from
you if you have makeup is it okay and
I've made them before but not really
like you know going into it and I need
like 13 or 14 for a bunch of family
members everybody fell in love they were
like these are so beautiful you need to
sell these you need to sell these so I
posted them in this Muslim networking
group and you know I got a lot of
enquiries and people were asking me but
it was towards the edge of the season so
I wasn't going to get a lot of
orders and all the time I got my first
order from a bride who wanted to wear it
for her wedding and I was so excited and
then I started getting other orders of
brides and other orders brides and I put
it on Instagram and I really wasn't like
trying to promote it hard for it it was
my whole family like literally somebody
asking where can I get a garland they
were tagging me so I can ask her she
makes great garland so I'm really lucky
that I have like extended family you
know just blasting my work out there I
started into them I you know I've been
getting orders I I'm booked through June
I actually have people putting deposits
down from January to June unfortunately
now because of the situation I had to
you know a lot of my brides had to
postpone I'm really lucky about every
bride that I've met has been super sweet
I haven't had to deal with a bridezilla
and you know for me it's just I like
doing it because for me to be a part of
somebody special day like a little
procedure to be a part of somebody
special day it is a blessing to me
literally literally every time every
time we had a customer buy wine from us
for their wedding or Bar Mitzvah or what
have you like I would always get a
little pep in my step because I knew it
was a special day and clothes is way
more powerful than wine so I totally get
it
go ahead you know the first flower
garland there look like lays almost and
it expands it is like fresh flower
jewelry for these women panel ceremony
and you know what he says and and you
know it's not huge but I'm not looking
to make it huge like I like to focus on
one piece at a time it's cut so much so
much yeah so what's the question cuz
this is going great question my question
now is that because I'm not getting
customers and I'm not I don't have
flowers on hand what kind of content
should I be creating just to keep that
myself visible a lot of people um I
think that there's a couple things I
would do one I would consider starting a
Facebook group for the community around
around the culture of these products and
so just
during a Facebook group just a talk just
there like people staying in touch I
think that you know like I've been
talking about it all week and last week
story time like just a video of you of
how this even happened is a good comic
book number one first album I would put
out that content you could absolutely
post right now on your Instagram or
anywhere else you have a community or
email and say hey does anybody want to
come on and do a video with me a live
stream where I can answer questions
about it like it now it is about you you
don't have the flowers you don't have
the product you're gonna have to make it
about you your family's journey you know
from Pakistan to the States store you
know put on you extended family allows
you to put on all of them
like this is the time to do story time
and and you know a video of how you
think about it like what happened the
process people loved the process you
know just like a story when I sit down I
can I don't know why but if I look at
the bride's photo or read the email I
just immediately see a vision and I
start working and you know like this is
it's time it's a it's about you now like
the same way that we fell in love in
America about Bureau Wang and her story
and are starting it at 40 and coming up
the ranks and we we need to this little
subset needs to fall in love with you
okay so what do you think about talking
to other wedding vendors and kind of
talking about what's going on now and
like the best course of action for
brides a hundred percent yeah if you
want to if you want to level up and be
the dinner host of a macro wedding
conversation and by DMing a hundred
people a day bizdev in that way I think
that's incredible yeah definitely
I love I mean I just want to shout out
to all these other Brown moms who are
entrepreneurs because I'm finding them
way crazy and I'm supporting them and
I'm tagging them and sharing their
stories and I'm so proud to see so what
many women coming tomorrow you know
coming up and just coming over
stereotypes I love it it's so amazing
unlimited like like like just you know
so many of the subcultures of brown you
know culture are so entrepreneurial by
Nature
the Internet has allowed mom to thrive
in a way that you know mom couldn't in
1974 and this is why I keep going back
to gratitude the [ __ ] Internet like
come on
magic Corona with pre-internet like we
get sick of television music and video
games pretty quickly in 1987 so like you
know like what a blessing yeah we can
definitely still connect with each other
and our parents and grandparents don't
have that opportunity during times of
you know it's another thing back to
immigrant culture so many people are
connecting with their loved ones now on
zoom and Google Hangouts cuz you know
that 60 70 80 90 year old said is being
forced to learn some technologies that
they've pushed against and they're
loving it and so that's been a great
gift that's been a great gift the amount
of people that are gonna interact with
their grandma back home in the old
country a hundred times more over the
next three years before she passes that
would have never happened on corona
because it was a once every six months
phone call and now it's a once a week
zoom on Friday nights it's a it's a
blessing there's so many blessings that
are coming I my grandfather used to send
audio cassettes to my dad like that's
old-school like he used to record an
audio because that cuz they didn't have
a phone so like when my parents came
here to America then we can save time
they wrote letters took letters don't
agree months to get here I mean so
anyway
alright Amira proud of you talking she's
on my scale
I don't see who say Anthony Fernandez in
the building again good to see them I am
if you're watching on Facebook right now
for the four thousand plus please hit
the share button and let's get some of
your friends and family onto this show
there are some gifts and jewels being
dropped let's keep this going hey
Lindsey hi Gary
how are you I'm tellin you I'm doing
good hanging in there are you from I'm
from the Jersey Shore so kind of close
to you yeah um so I want us to tell you
how I actually found you you showed up
on my Instagram Explorer like maybe over
the summer and it was when you were
doing like sleep yard sailing
so that's kind of like my business
that's what I started out doing I grew
up with from a teen mom so I lived with
my grandparents my mom like we didn't we
were good things recovered but like at
the end of the month there wasn't always
a lot left over so we were always like
super always out like at the flea
markets or just trying to make things
work I wouldn't I wouldn't say I was
like entrepreneurial and then I went to
college for advertising and then it was
like my school year we were leaving and
I noticed people were throwing furniture
away on the curse year and I was like my
favor who had a pickup truck I just
grabbed all the furniture I brought it
home and I sold it on Craigslist and
like some of it I painted some of I sold
it as is and then I was like this is
insane so yeah so I worked in corporate
America for ten years but like painting
furniture and reselling it on Craigslist
and now Facebook marketplace was always
like my side has side hustle yeah and
then three years ago I had my son and I
was like oh man I don't want to leave
and go to work and then come home and be
miserable so I'm just gonna like go full
force into my business so I did yeah so
it kind of went from like painting
furniture and just posting it on
Craigslist to like you know kind of
getting a little bit of notoriety in my
town and then I was taking on Commission
work and then I was looking for places
to get like stuff to put on my furniture
to take pictures so then I kind of got
into antiques and it kind of like
spiraled
um and then I was like maybe I show up
in a brick-and-mortar store but then I
was like I don't know it's a commitment
so then I found an antique mall actually
in Point Pleasant New Jersey so I pay
them roll it and I have a booth there
and I was like yes this is so smart and
strategic I'm only paying like 550 bucks
a month on my rent I don't have to be
there I don't worry about sales I can
just get my stuff bring it there do this
stuff I love which is hunting for the
stuff and be creative and then
coronavirus happened and my store closed
and I still have to come up with my rent
and I'm like I can't go to the flea
markets I can't go to anywhere and we're
kind of just like stuck in the house and
I'm like okay yeah and like my art and
like I know you get it cuz I saw it in
your face when you were like going to
flea markets like it's like your thrill
of the hunt like you might like it's
like I'm gonna pull like you pull
something on you're like this was $2.00
I can sell this for 50 and like I can't
do that anymore so it's almost like
you're like a caged animal I mean I'm so
devastated that we're gonna miss you
know town-wide garage sales season here
in Jersey for April and May
you can't even imagine it's like running
through my mind left and right a couple
things stand out one you can definitely
garage sale in your own home okay I
think people are you know it's unlikely
that you have as much stuff as most
people because you actually get it so so
one and I mean it's really going through
everything that's in the house and maybe
getting a little bit of that flipped
life out of your system but - I'm a
little bit of an idealist
I think that you can create a little 15
or 20 dollar course on and I think your
angle is like flipping and creativity I
think you can put together you know an
80 90 page PDF okay right
and then also layer and then market it
like this hey I've created
85 page book and I'm doing a once a week
one hour Zoomer Google hangout okay and
it costs 90 bucks and you get the book
and you get me for you know four four
sessions or however you want to play it
maybe you build up the momentum and
launch it in a month because thank you
some time to put the PDF together I
think what you do which is a little bit
more Etsy thrift store creative it's not
just what I do which is like buy stuffed
animals sell stuff yeah you know you're
doing doing a lot of creativity and the
DUI world you know I was laughing when
you said I'm not an entrepreneur I'm
like you are an entrepreneur and a
creative one and so my intuition is you
have the potential of having a community
through your inbox your email what I
mean by that your your cell phone
numbers your texts I don't know what you
do on social if you've got a little bit
of following anywhere but I think it's
following I think if you put out like
hey here's an $89 program where you get
a 80 page PDF 6040 112 and you get for
one-hour sessions with me live you know
in in the month from mid-april to
mid-may I have a funny feeling you would
do really well okay I just worry because
my audience and I was like super local
to the Jersey Shore people that I've met
at like markets that I've done and
they're like but no buy for me like they
and then it seemed like yeah I don't
know how many of them want to be an
entrepreneur and want to do what you're
doing and in fact you're giving away all
your best advice and QA access and not
to mention that okay so Pam in Red Bank
sees it but then she tags her sister
Susan in Australia who's been wanting to
do something like this and is creative
and she puts her username in the
comments and then she's the one that
actually buys the $89 you know ebook and
access ok this is a good point and then
like in terms of like I just feel
awkward right now like hulking pieces
that I'm working on like yeah I think I
think you
right I think you just write the copy
upfront which is like first and foremost
I hope everybody's healthy I have no you
know you know obviously all of us are
going through this struggle so please
before even look at this desk you don't
know that I'm super empathetic and and
care about everybody first and foremost
but the same token I'm also trying to
provide for my family and so here's my
desk I think if you if you write the
hedge in the first two sentences I think
it will help you okay all right good
luck
all right let's keep this going Bobby
thank you so much big shout out to
Charlie Whitmore the share he gets a
follow number 437 hello
buenos Diaz oh my god my heart is
pounding really fast and I help people
deal with their nerves and their
confidence thank you so much welcome
what's your name nice to me maritza
coscarelli I am the daughter of
Dominican immigrants into Washington hi
it's the wife of an Italian immigrant
himself came when he was 11 and I I knew
about you and followed you you know
dabbled in your work at first and then I
saw you with Sasha this weekend and you
guys just stole my heart thank you so
much for your authenticity and
everything I am a white chocolate mom
preneur so a dominican white woman brown
woman whatever I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't believe in labels that puts us in
boxes my passion I came from a
background I was a performing
professional ballet and contemporary
dancer with ballet with New York and
smileth harp and a bunch of great people
that was like Volume one
I married Joe 33 years ago we became
best friends 40 years ago in parlin new
jersey you are in a photo on my nephews
my best friend's son's Facebook they ran
into you guys recycling in Nutley one
day Michael and Nicholas lick Amelie
he's a physical therapist and a
carpenter you remember them we were
flipping it was when I was doing trash
talk I do remember we're very dear
friends Leslie and I their mother our
friend since the third grade and the
father is friends with my husband since
the sixth grade
just a little background on logic we all
have a community my work then led me to
the fitness world where I was what they
call a lifestyle director I personal
trained I ran spas and fitness centers
in luxury condos and hotels in Miami New
York and I live in Palm Beach now when
we left New York and New Jersey we were
like the escaping the 36
first cousins it was a big deal my
in-laws cried like they were at our
funeral and we built a house near st.
Augustine and I started a little dance
studio in my house and eventually I had
a brick and mortar at a Publix Plaza and
I had over 250 students Joe and I have
relocated almost 19 times because in the
auto industry and he became a fixer like
often dealership or you'll sell it or
whatever I got it he's still in that
work 33 years later 32 years later we've
got two amazing kids Alyssa in the city
on Instagram 310 K followers Russian
stylist editor curator amazing 26 Joseph
31 pop culture music journalist for the
New York Times Diary of a song he made
up for them facetiming with pop artists
and their producers on a quick FaceTime
that he runs as a video for them and a
Simon & Schuster book deal for him I
fell in love with Tom Levine yesterday
and I know I said I will be your
confidence coach I love the arch and he
said I'll book a call so we're in I love
that I love that my son and Tom - - the
love for himself I gave a keynote at an
event a few years ago that changed my
coaching business my business is emcee
coaching dot life I started it it should
be maritza coscarelli coaching I get
that that's coming you don't need my
name but when I realized you're in koba
to get to my question how am i building
this business I have I invested when I
had nothing
I'm plastic I invested in one of the
best business coaches and mindset
coaches Fabian Frederick's in a bold
heart who is speaking
all of honor to you lately I was on a
live with her Q & A Saturday and she was
saying Jab Jab Jab right hook like pick
it up now Gary's got me doing a lot more
repurposing and she has a multi-million
dollar business
Ibn with full heart so I invested what I
didn't have in that business coach
because I was spinning wheels alone
thinking that I'm supposed to be
self-sufficient the immigrant mind
figured out that life-changing but I
know I'm still not generous enough still
not doing all the things the question I
had texted in was if you could tell me
one thing around content around my
differentiator around how to put myself
out in a big way you know when you say
your big dream I have expanded myself
enough to say I am I don't even like
saying but Tony Robbins because I just
want to say the marritza coscarelli of
women middle age and a few amazing men
to fall in love with themselves to get
clear on their messaging and to
persevere to the dream that they want
because I've lived several dreams I
don't have money to show for it but I
got a lot of heart and I'm gonna get the
money because I'm going to help so many
people let me let me promise you this if
you've had enough money to pay the bills
enough to have a lot of heart
you [ __ ] one person being very
serious with you like a just even
thinking about business coaches and how
entrepreneurial you are and just
listening before before I go into the
answer and I have very good insight I
think it's gonna help you I really
really want to make sure like like I
promise you you were just so happy and
charismatic right now like I can't wait
to look at the Twitter stream in between
your call and the next one because you
just made half the audience fall in love
with you I just want to say this very
slowly it's very important to me
much like Jo like fixes like when you go
and you operate you look at where
they're wasting money who the bad
employees are it's like bar rescue right
you come in you audit and you fix it
right and then they either flip it I
think about that practical when I when I
hear your story please do not put you
know putting money in the bank or buying
something bigger on a pedestal you've
got way too much happiness pouring out
of you so I'm a little bit less worried
about and actually you know I'm really
excited right now because it's gonna
lead to my answer
you're the biggest issue a coach has
with the world I live in is
subconsciously even when their sweetest
[ __ ] pie like you are subconsciously
ninety-nine percent of their con
they put out on the Internet is in the
intent of a lead-gen to get them to sign
up
you've been in the subscription business
your whole life right you had the studio
250 people they were paying a monthly
fee to go there right you're in a
coaching framework now which I'm sure
sits in probably a monthly fee or a
one-time fee and what what people
struggle with is when they're putting
out an Instagram a YouTube starting a
podcast doing zooms and hangouts like
this you know you know Connie you know
practically you understand that it is
putting yourself out there and putting
out good information the big reason I've
been able to ascend to a different level
than the far majority of people that
look like me is because I have zero
intent to get one dollar from you and
that's the end right you have two
children I do as well
that's called unconditional love as much
as we love our friends as much as we
love our best friends that we've known
since third grade we would cut those
people for our children right it's just
the way it is in that because you do
love that friend that you've had since
they're great you do love that first
cousin you do love other people in that
little Delta of your children versus the
everybody else is the magic and that is
the small variance that I need for I
need you to understand the following
that you need to produce unlimited
content and unlimited access let people
go on zoom' with you it holds a hundred
people you just talk you just shoot the
[ __ ] if you get to a place mentally
where you can do a one or two hour
Facebook live or zoom or or hang out and
have zero mentions of your coaching zero
you will be stunned by how much that
leads to actual coaching I love that I
can commit to that I have no like I
don't feel any resistance or
reservations to that I do click to
something that leads to one more quick
thing that we saw the ship's really
happen which is immediately like from
this high I got this like the deflation
of a balloon when it goes I got that
around okay so I come out there and I
got two or three people
in there and I have a lot of people like
I've met networking live that are now
networking with me on zoom' I was on a
BNI at 7 o'clock this morning like the
work ethic is there and those people
were sending me texts during the BNI
like we love you so much we're so happy
you're part of our club thank you for
what you do for us right but I the
attraction like I study I'm a yogi of 20
years a meditator I study law of
attraction all of that I get that work
and I'm wondering what is the missing
link right now what is the shift I have
to make to attract and at the intime to
getting out in a bigger way oh yes I
mean I think it's the I think it's the
intent you know right now you're so and
I loved where you're at I think it's a I
think it's not a bad thing but I do
think it's a thing I think the intent is
I'm gonna build I'm gonna do this thing
and then four people are gonna sign up
for coaching you're not wrong
I know Marissa my husband I know you're
right no way I know I'm ready you'll
appreciate this I actually know that
which is why I'm giving you this advice
I said I don't blame you for that you're
trying to build a business it's just
that I need you to separate church and
state when you make content you are
marritza full heart and then you come
out of it when you're done and maybe
there'll be some things there to do
business Jab Jab Jab right hook
give give give and then you can ask and
something will happen what I'm very good
at I'll give you an example I put out
everything for free have no coaching
have no master I have no island it's all
[ __ ] free then occasionally I put out
things like hey would you sign up for
wine text and buy wine for my dad's
business and then people that have gone
and taken all the concept of free and
changed their financial and Happiness
life will still go to Publix and Ralph's
and BevMo and Total Wine and buy wine
and not buy from wine texts and the fact
that I am NOT disappointed in that is
why I win
there are hundreds of thousands of
people there are thousands people
watching right now who've gotten
extraordinary levels of value for me who
buy wine at the supermarket on wine calm
and have not signed up for wine text to
school my dad not even me and and I'm ok
with that that that is the punch that's
the foot you want to talk about a
[ __ ] secret not being disappointed
when you've given so much and somebody
hasn't had the ability to connect the
dots to give a little bit back to put a
little karma back into you and you're
still not disappointed in them and
you're still not sad for yourself do you
know many people who sell courses and
all this like like like the like the
lowest common denominator guy and gal
out there making millions selling
[ __ ] make fun of me behind my back
in that in those inner circles because
they think they make so much more money
than me the [ __ ] comes to use Moritz
the [ __ ] confused hey I'm gonna make
way more money than them because I'm
more talented be I'm gonna be around
forever they're not see I'm a better
human being and putting more kindness
into the world they're not you know when
I texted again yesterday one of the
things I said as a new question was I'm
open I want Gary to call me on my
[ __ ] and it's so weird when we know
things intellectually but we're not
really rolling that way so for the last
three Gary tea with Gary B's I've been
on and at the same time I'm like oh [ __ ]
two hours in my day like I'm trying to
work and listen and whatever but my
point is this I know for sure because I
wrote a blog and I don't write blogs
regularly I'm gonna get on it but I
wrote radical generosity I know the keys
to happiness and the first one of them
is radical generosity and I mean radical
and again I'm not practicing it I say I
show people how to show up authentically
I am authentic it's Who I am right but I
say I do it so they lead with heart like
my heart is freaking open I see it so I
see it I see it
and I'm not saying much I hope all show
you yeah also it's about expectations
yeah I don't have I don't have the
expectation for anybody to do anything
in return for something I don't give
giving
giving and and right now in coaching
land I see a lot of sweet people
manipulating their half their half their
best selves because if they leave a
little back
they hope the person comes in and pays
them 200 bucks a month can I just say
one little thing Gary about my story
that just dropped in and so it feels
like I'm compelled to share it so I had
suicidal ideation a lot of times when
Joe and I first got married there was a
major betrayal he had a serious
addictive problem and hid it from me for
all the years we dated and it hissed and
he left me a Dear John no first year a
marriage
lease is up I called the building
management and I said listen I have a
personal problem crying right there how
do I renew my least they said honey your
lease was up yesterday you got to be out
in two days
picked up the phone and call the Luka
Mellie's best friends called my parents
pack the boxes he said I can't tell you
where I am cuz I'm in deep [ __ ] and I
don't want you to be in trouble like
these things these kinds of things
happened in oh wait bought the freaking
big mansion dream home he worked for
General Motors I tried to a mortgage
adjustment on my own I nearly took my
own life thinking that a freaking thing
was worth it but it was really about
what will I tell the family what will I
tell my kids like I have other plans
I used to think that I didn't survive
anything because I didn't have breast
cancer or something I have survived all
that and learned to thrive I wake up
ready to go and I know that that's a
value to people it isn't about me it's
about we've all got residual Marissa
totally written - yeah put that out for
free yeah and then if they happen to
want to have one-on-one access to you
then then then Mazel Tov but if you
don't put up for free yeah you don't put
that out for free
you'll never attract because the intent
is to funnel them not to save them
I got it I got the takeaway and I got
what I wanted because I wanted some
state church and state give give give
give give give give and then something's
gonna happen that's a little shift right
now it's happening and I am going to act
on it today I love you good luck thank
you so much you're welcome so much that
was a good one I think that's gonna help
a lot of people who are trying to sell
who are some nice people
man this is great Kristi Richards thanks
for watching thank you so much Oh Annie
freed with the with the I love this this
is that this right here is my favorite
screen the wine Tex confirmation Dustin
it's more fun for me to get people to
sign up for wine text for my dad because
he gets so excited at night when I see
him here cuz I'm hanging with them doing
this thing like 84 you know it's
literally more fun for like literally we
close like a four million dollar piece
of business the other day and like three
people signing up right now and sharing
on Twitter the confirmation screen to
wine text is more excited than that deal
that's when you know what you're about
all right let's keep it going
hello Lana how are you I it Lana like
Lana bananas pleasure Lana I love your
background I want to sell all of it on
eBay
well yeah you're so amazing thank you
for doing that uh it's a lot more
time-consuming than I thought
but I'm home monthly work unfortunate
unfortunate that I have a job that I
actually was not I'm very well I'm very
very well I'm all right
what can I help you with i yeah I my
question my original question actually
you've been answered pretty much because
I've been watching um I know you know
great chocolate has burned for a long
time in Korea and but my whole life I
have stuff spins in my head all of these
ideas and I harass and torture and my
family oh oh I could do this or like my
kids oh you guys do this um and um I
finally a lot of personal things happen
and place in my life where I make sense
it makes sense people people that love
the word should are always scared Wow
yeah isn't that funny and I never
realized all these bad decisions I can
go back to whatever but they find it
really is that all of those things I
chose to be in like for whatever reason
and that I was always afraid to change
it um and once I figured that out that I
don't have to stay in this job I don't
have this marriage or whatever it was um
it was for bounce I have like
major breakdown you know hysterical let
it all out and I know that together that
I am better than all of that so it's
been very exciting actually for me
because now I'm like I kind of started
small like wait you know I'm like and I
give you that like running a marathon I
hate running
I hate more than Lana have you have you
thought about sharing this and putting
out content and inspiring others because
what you're doing takes an enormous
amount of courage and I'm getting
inspired in the last 45 seconds because
I'll tell you because I'll tell you
you're inherently private you know I
can't even tell in this thing so like
putting that out more I actually think
is gonna lead to more light to more
happiness and I'm totally I'm already
gonna do yeah hi and my are adults now
you know I have my whole life I choose
what I wanted you Lana how did how did
you first find my content by accident I
was you know I'm like the video is fun
watching the video and you know I'll
start rolling on Facebook and then there
you are and the first one was actually
when you were talking about college and
kids because like kids constantly like
saying you know encouraged and when you
were talking about call it's not being
worthwhile and it really hit me to get
ready
you know hit you you mean you realize
that college is not for everyone yeah
[Music]
why aren't they getting better grades
and and there's no there's no there's no
correlation between good grades and
happiness that is something that parents
have to learn the nth confidence
self-esteem self-esteem I hope to see an
here's good news here's the good news
the good news in the same way that you
kind of had this awakening no more like
Lana out of this call which obviously
your questions got answered so now we're
just riffing listen to me don't dwell
just do Nate Welling just do it it
doesn't matter how you did it in the
past you have your whole life and their
whole life to change the words that come
out of your mouth you can start now it's
not too late it's just not yeah well
it's it's clear to me which is why which
is why I'm like trying to pound into
your head listen to me it just doesn't
matter there is no changing that there's
no [ __ ] time machines gives a [ __ ]
like you know and and people want to
dwell because dwelling is similar to
should it's an excuse not to do
you understand you know state staying in
that well I [ __ ] like it just it's an
excuse not to do and the fact that you
[ __ ] ran this marathon you need to do
the you did the physical version of it
now you need to do the emotional version
of it every single day so I have you
know a lot of ideas and I can you do me
can you do me a favor can you put it on
a dartboard and throw a dart or or or
just close your eyes and poke a pen to
one of them and just do it I'm going to
I'm and I appreciate Lana Lana just pick
one and then after four months if you
don't like it you didn't waste time you
learn oh you like it and then the next
thing on the list all right Lana thank
you so much have a great day
take care
you
yes life two years that's what I told
you last night I know I told you you
didn't hear me last night yeah Jim hey
how are you I'm good
what's up what's going on is you have a
tremendous set up behind you I'm very
impressed sir yeah I have a bunch of
stuff going I see it where you from Long
Island
Smith Alex yeah sure yeah yeah um where
can I start so many amazing people on
this show yesterday Tom today maritza so
much we're building a little community
here and I feel like I got a lot of
answers okay out of all the other so so
why don't we do this which makes sense
why don't we do this cuz a lot of to
your point a lot of things have common
themes let's let's do this cuz I think
this is really fun
what would you like to happen like what
are you doing and what would you what do
you think as of this second
theoretically would make you happy
whether in your soul or professionally
like how are you thinking about that
that's a good starting point yeah
so I do this live interview show
Smithtown life I'd like to get you know
more involved with that but then that
takes away from my real estate business
so that's that's my big question well
let's talk about that that's a great
question you're about to help a lot of
people Jim so there's Smithtown live
which is your side hustle your hobby
that probably in the back you mind if
you can get enough advertisers and the
viewers you'd love to do full-time
because you [ __ ] love it
yeah yeah and then there's the real
estate business which pays the bills and
there's a real business you know by you
so you'd like to have more time for
Smithtown live because the real estate
takes up time it's obviously this mattel
live is the thing you loves makes sense
right so the biggest question I have and
a lot of people live in this scenario is
what give me a typical day pre corona
how many hours on a Monday through
Friday or the week however you want to
position it would you spend on on real
estate tell me the truth don't [ __ ]
me
how many hours the for the for the real
estate for the week 16 per day per day
or the week however you want to do a
typical day typical day 810 hours
between prospecting and analyzing in
webinars and what what takes up time
between visa town lives and the work my
losing track and signing up for webinars
and you know I I get lost really quick
you know I can watch two hours of
garyvee and then you know I'm like oh
crap I got to go and do that right you
know I enjoy learning you enjoy I absorb
I go on YouTube you know yeah yeah I get
it so so with how is Smithtown like
doing is it a podcast is it a youtube
show what is it you know what it's they
started out to be live live local
interviews they were pre recorder and
then I put them out as a night alive
yeah
how many have you done probably a little
over 20 25 accepting them into zoom
calls I'm calling all the local
businesses that block that chamber that
night let's go live I'm doing one
tonight and I'm going to come kind of
combine into like a tribute show with a
pizza are you I love that are you are
you doing this as a hobby because you
love your local town or is there a part
of you that hopes that all the local
businesses kind of find a way to give
you 500 to a thousand a month as a
sponsor and this becomes your business
um you know I'm not really looking for
sponsorship it for me it was it was more
I wanted to for my town and then that
brings awareness to you to bring more
was that something that you'd had heard
from me three years because I'm a big
fan of this thesis Greg listen well
listen then I'm thrilled because to your
point I was kind of hoping you would go
there like brother
make 2200 I want the principal I want
the mayor I want every single [ __ ]
business I want parents I want the high
school coach like just pay em yeah so
now that's been a that's been a little
bit of an obstacle as I go to businesses
and they're like they they always think
I'm coming in with a ploy don't tell
them you're not tell that I go there's
no charge to you
you know something hard good news then
go to the next one yeah you haven't
asked every business you haven't asked
every local official you haven't asked
every you just have it
well on or try to commence somebody
don't convince anybody just ask the next
person Jim one of the biggest reason a
lot of people really struggle with sales
is they put so much energy convincing
someone instead of realizing just go to
the next person okay no convincing just
jumping to the next opportunity yeah
because let me promise you when this
starts getting going then the ice cream
shops gonna be saying [ __ ] why did the
tire store and the florist and the
therapists get this and I didn't I got a
callback that guy what's his name again
James Johnny you know what I mean yeah
got it yeah so um what is the second so
how do so how do you parlay the real
estate and the Smith down live together
I know like you threw up your little
text for wine yesterday but I'm trying
to keep them separate I think separates
gonna work I think you post them on goo
you post them on YouTube you posted you
put them show everywhere yeah dad that's
gonna index on search and inevitably
you're gonna make one video that people
to understand it's about 800 videos that
do nothing for you and then one video
with a dentist that for some reason
populates to the top of Google search
right and all of a sudden when people
are thinking about this town to move to
it they see this video of you they
really you know you you end it with you
know this is Jim Hayden and you know I'm
a real estate agent this wonderful town
and you've been listening to Smith town
live and they're like wait a minute he's
a real estate agent and away you go
that's why I like principals and
superintendents and teachers because
school districts are a big part of
people deciding so if they if you're the
one who interviewed all the teachers and
all the coaches and all the principals
you've got a real shot of showing up
somewhere on their search and their
homework which then leads to trust which
then leads to you being their real
estate agent okay got it okay yeah
that's what you got - can I uh another
question in real quick yeah I get though
this whole Quran it's a
like you know everybody's how do I
motivate other agents around me and and
myself you know I just ain't ha there
you go
mg so you know I just came from you know
I took a couple months off my brother
passed away sorry to hear that
yeah um now I'm back and then often this
corona thing happens brother honestly
Jim you you know what you and I have the
pleasure of we've lived life a little
bit right we're not 20 right you've
lived life you know that this is part of
the game unfortunately I mean that is
dead listen I'm talking like a big shot
I don't know it might take me years to
recover from a siblings death like I I
can't even like I can't even like
project that pain hey don't beat
yourself up if you're not motivated yet
because maybe you're not done you know
morning right yeah the corona thing is
the corona thing like guess what it's
better than the Black Plague guess what
it's better than World War two so like
you know like not just you that's just
something that happens this is a time to
be grateful for your health and the
other people that you love be grateful
for the opportunity and I would just go
ham on content creation but not try to
commence just just there's plenty of
teachers right now willing to talk about
how they're getting through Corona how
they like to town their career everybody
wants a little bit most people want a
little bit of Fame and so if you ask to
have them on the show you'll do quite
well just pile into your passion which
is this you know using Smithtown to
build up the real estate thing it will
work you just have to put out the
content brother I put out [ __ ] years
of why not why every dude my new you
from way way back in the day so I'm
actually gonna send you his book he just
finished up before he passed away please
please do that so eat send me mail too I
love that I'd like to honor him by
checking out that book so Gary at
vaynermedia
good luck Jim put out the content don't
convince just do okay thank you thank
you both take care I just let's keep it
going a lot of emotions here on a team
with Gary Vee this day
okay the Wellness have it thank you
thank you so much for saying
be by the cloud going Gary what's good
Robert hey sorry I'm dropping to work
right now but I've been listening you
all born it beautiful grow just keep
your eyes on the road you talk I'll
listen all right all right all right you
know I guess I know you're on a roll
here some try to keep it going
I know I'm a hardy BFS man I never did
nothing like this from my question this
is already killing me because I don't do
well with the public view and it's kind
of so I guess make it easy for me to
keep my eyes on the road and I make on
there is no stupid Robert Robert there
is no stupid bro there's just the [ __ ]
that's on your mind
I really wish people realize that there
is no stupid there's no smarter stupid
question on some real [ __ ]
there's just Robert living his [ __ ]
life and has a random thought get that
[ __ ] stupid get that thought out of
your like let me cut that [ __ ] out of
your mind right now forever there is no
[ __ ] stupid there's just you there's
just me there's just Dustin there's just
Jim like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
who who gets to say something stupid
[ __ ] that probably going to tell me that
I'm too young to worry about this [ __ ]
but one of the things I struggle with
most right now man enough 27 years old I
got three beautiful kids and a beautiful
wife and I struggled with trying to make
life in my eyes worthy for them it's for
my children in the future I love that so
first of all let me give you some good
news the fact that you even care about
that means that you're gonna make it
worthy
I think Robert might be going through a
patch Javan Dan Robert yep I'm Eric so
Robert the fact that you even care about
that means that you're gonna make it
worthy bro do not make this about
anything other than giving love it with
the proper intent it's as simple as that
like like you're gonna make it worthy by
actually hearing to make it worthy and
loving the end it's not gonna be worthy
because of stuff it's not gonna be
worthy because of professional
accomplishment it's gonna be worthy
because you [ __ ] loved right right
you're absolutely right like what you're
gonna like worthy because you got a
bigger house worthy because you put an
extra zero in the bank account what's
worthy were these about you loving those
[ __ ] and putting self-esteem in them
yeah I just want them to know that
something more incident what I can offer
them as far as what I have to offer I
want them to know that the world is
theirs then you take it to get back and
do whatever they want Robert just pumped
that [ __ ] into their head pump it Pump
it 24/7 love opportunity you can bro
people don't look at their parents based
on their professional or financial
accomplishments they look at them based
on what they put in their [ __ ] dome I
know bro I meet I meet people all the
time that have gone on to have happy
successful life's that came from parents
that had breezy humble beginnings
because their parents made them believe
and it wasn't and and kids aren't gonna
come at their parents are like well why
didn't you
and you're gonna say here were my
circumstances here's what happened you
keep it real as [ __ ] but you tell them
but that was my circumstances your
circumstances you got me and I'm gonna
[ __ ] take you to the top mentally
right right see that's the kind of
person I am so I'm always I've always
been raised that way I mean for you know
a little differently you know my dad was
a Mary he wasn't a person for words he
was very physical with me you know for
somebody like that I grew up they kind
of forced me into this kind of a show so
another part of my question was
I always I was always somewhat of the
class clown you know what I mean I was
that kid i was that performer but now
that i'm older or not now we're in this
world of producing content excuse me and
put our stuff on social media i always
find myself at that block but where I
can't do it because I feel that rain of
judgement just just lashing down and on
me like you're not funny here not this
you can't bro first of all the scruff
looks good you're I'm we're really
trying to do so you're being plenty
beautiful don't worry about that listen
to me your dad your aunt nobody gets to
decide besides the market you need to
get on tik-tok make some funny [ __ ] try
your best the market gets decide there
is no human that gets to decide the
market aka the world
get up listen to me get crazy about tick
tock tick tock is the place for funny
tick tocks a safe place right now it's
very nice because it's early just
Twitter was nice at first Instagram was
nice at first that's how they all work
Facebook was like it's it's nice right
now and it's about funny you need to go
in there and try bro you're 27 bro your
[ __ ] kid can't grow you know me then
like you you're it's the truth you're a
[ __ ] kid love your children make them
feel the opposite of what your dad made
you feel they'll learn that that was
your story and then you'd be grateful
for what you did for them and then
that's one chapter and then on the other
side go make funny [ __ ] and when your
friend or your uncle or somebody says
the [ __ ] are you wasting your time for
you look them dead in the face and you
tell me you worried about you you worry
about you [ __ ] you you worry about you
right like every time somebody's come at
me hard growing up or in life like why
are you doing this I go right at them
like a [ __ ] gangster I'm like why are
you drinking that night when nobody's
paying attention you know like listen
you know what I mean [ __ ] them go into a
cocoon you've heard me say that if you
know who I am
quiet love your kids make them feel they
can do anything in the world but don't
be delusional
don't tell me can dunk if they're only
give me five seven you know what I mean
I'm going macro bro not literally no but
listen to me listen to me build
self-esteem in them which is
unfortunately not when you were
fortunate in getting and then go make
funny [ __ ] on that is the [ __ ] you
don't think listening don't think for
six months no thinking no thinking no
valuing how many views how many
followers no numbers no thinking make
make make make make every little awesome
creative thing running through your
beautiful brain make make make got it
okay got it thank you thank got you
alright get into a little bit roll here
now I'm feeling it gonna have so much
Celeste I love it alright alright chené
chené Zaloom you got it you asked me I'm
your 16th [ __ ] follower Big Ups to
Costa Rica Celeste hey what's up how are
things good I I'm just I work out of my
home so everything's kind of the same
inside it just feels really weird and
ominous outside so I just wanted it I
think you forgive me the opportunity
beyond here and Brendan you're doing and
you help just daily so so I own a small
business I have for five years and so I
know without risking I guess seeming
insensitive with everything that's going
on my I guess what I would want to know
from like your perspective is like what
is the positive like what is the most
positive thing that's gonna come out of
this cuz like you know I know for me
you know I I definitely feel impacted my
business feels impacted and it's a
little bit uncertain and a little scary
orbits that's how I pay my bills and you
know it's been a really like rough five
years with you know like the distro of
sorrow with owning your own business and
so I I'm I'm finding like a lot of
inspiration in trying to like be of
service in anyway like because I don't
have kids that aren't in daycare I don't
have kids that I have to homeschooling
I'm not like I'm impacted obviously but
I'm not like suffering and so I'm I see
it as like an opportunity to like we
values less real quick real quick so you
don't put guilt on you because I
appreciate the energy you're coming with
not like like a shocking amount of
people aren't that extraordinary amount
of people are loving this vacation
because Jenny an extraordinary amount of
people don't have responsibilities and
extraordinary people's businesses are
thriving because they sell food on the
internet and people are buying work so
hey hey don't worry about don't beat
yourself up for worrying about you and
potentially even seeing opportunity
that's okay you're supposed to worry
about you right and you can have
compassion and sympathy and empathy for
others I see nothing but opportunity for
four hours and then I go on for 15
minutes with my admin and we send a
bunch of masks to hospitals because I
can afford it and if you can't that's
also fine you just saying prayers and
calling people and checking in you going
to your phone right now and texting five
people that used to be friends or
acquaintances of yours that you haven't
talked to in four years and just saying
hey taking advantage of this time to
like see how you're doing and just
sending a little love and showing that
you care that's powerful so don't beat
yourself up a let's start there okay I
mean it's it's tough because it's like I
do you know when you do something that
is not for like just the benefit of you
or your business or whatever like you
know you do feel good so you know it's
it's hard to exactly are saying not
filled go in a lot of ways that you're
not like you know super my I listened to
the things I was saying and I saved
money which allowed me to do nice things
like I'm doing
right now for hospitals and workers and
different things and employees and all
the things I'm doing other people either
were silly and bought dumb [ __ ] or just
never won a place where they had too
much College dead or something horrible
happened they didn't save and so what
what but they want to do something good
they can do positive things
I'm telling you texting old friends and
saying hello and thinking about you and
caring about you is a great deed and
putting out good karma to the universe
is a great deed so everybody can do
stuff so we put that on the side what
can I help you with for you so so I
guess like I having said all that and
kind of realizing that there is a lot of
opportunity to spy it like the crisis
that everyone's kind of facing is like
so for me like I've noticed so I'm a
small business and I you know I am very
supportive of other might like my
friends and just people that I know that
are customers of mine that also have
small businesses like I've been
encouraging like people to go and tag
their small business or one that they
love or their friends like on my patient
I've been you you'll preciate this
building slash aspiring is not something
that's going to do overwhelmingly well
right you know let that by the way
that's not to discourage you because
you're doing a wonderful act I just want
to give you the mindset of humans right
now like I'm watching all these people
like supporting small business and then
I am watching and reading and paying
attention then people like that's cool
but I don't want to [ __ ] buy you know
a a pizza right now I'm [ __ ] scared
shitless about like my business my job
you know what I mean like so just keep
that in mind
it's almost like you know just keep that
in mind so and that's like the thin line
that I'm I'm walking so my business is
like I design and I sell women's
athletic like athleisure apparel and so
I just we like I rebranded at the end of
last year and I used to just be like a
regular EECOM store and so now I do
limited edition releases so the you know
the concept it allows me to be able to
design and be way ask you question can
you afford to do a drop where you give
profits to you know nurses and and
doctors I don't think I can afford to do
some of it yeah yeah I would I would I
would design something right now
that incorporates like maybe you know
like they I guess the Red Cross you know
like they're you know like like
incorporates that whole movement I bet
you that could be some sort of viral
moment and could really build awareness
for you you survive your your overhead
and rented all that you feel amazing
because you've given a to your local
hospital right cuz even if it's a $500
you buy $500 worth of masks and you
donate giving is well you can afford to
give I used to give nine dollars and now
I don't I give more you know like you
know it's you know changes and it's also
a thing that can build brand for you
because people appreciative that you're
stepping up which then may lead to
business where we get out of here
so that might be a model to think about
especially if you made the application
design as a pre-sale limited-edition
drop that incorporated what's going on
right now maybe you mask said maybe
there you know you see where I'm going
yeah yeah that's awesome that's like
such a dope idea and and that's like
kind of what I was looking forward
something to like you know getting
behind without it being incest that's
what team with Gary B's [ __ ] all about
it's you know it's it's how I live I
live in them in the macro the clouds the
mindset and then in the dirt right the
tactics I play back and forth some of
this stuff has you've been watching is
for people here for you right now I'm
super pumped because that's a real
tactic that's gonna [ __ ] work and
that's gonna work and god forbid a que
God willing somebody in news is gonna
see that local news thing and have you
on resume and talk about why you did and
like there's something really big on
this side yeah I hope you do it ASAP
okay thank you so much that's so don't
you sitting all right Dustin showing my
chops your [ __ ] Christine
are you high are you good
there we go okay way to make sure you
had it set up right yeah bit set up
right what's good so first I want to
just give a just give big love to people
out there that are going through a tough
time right now I have two people very
special in my life that are going
through some different things my
brother's a captain in the army who just
retired his ceremony has been canceled
naturally also my best friend Kristen
down in South Florida lost her dad at
the beginning of the month had to cancel
a celebration of life ceremony I was
actually supposed to fly and I got sick
myself couldn't doubt it so I blame her
for everybody that is dealing with
things like that I feel very fortunate
that we not gone one haven't had
anything tragic like that happen my high
schooler is not a senior but what's kind
of cool as the things I've been seeing
from seniors are taking it well you know
they're having fun with it and just
really making the best of it it's 20% I
mean listen it's devastating to lose
your prom and your graduation but this
is a real pandemic I mean we're gonna
start seeing two per thousand people
3,000 people a day die we need to have
perspective like and we need to innovate
like I can't wait to see the first you
know high school do an entire prom on
zoom' like there's so much fun [ __ ] you
can do so innovation comes from
adversity and I think we'll see a lot of
cool [ __ ] Cristina didn't agree more
what's cooking what can I help you with
so so my question to you was how do you
have any advice on balance I mean I've
heard you talk about it before I
struggle with it personally I don't know
if you can see there's my cat acute you
guys might know that my cat is an
Internet cat on Instagram I do struggle
though with keeping up with everything
that you know that entails keep being
engaged with the fans and the e-mails
back and forth tonight can I give you a
quick prescription that you're gonna
love yes you see it's you are keeping up
with it you're just judging yourself I
am but I feel like because I was like I
can do more I feel like I'm falling
short
and I feel in case you're coaching
yourself you're judging it
that's mmmm I judge myself all the time
and very sometimes well well I've great
news it's the number one [ __ ] thing
we have to figure out because I could
even feel it in your energy and that
makes me happy I just want to get around
your potty I'm being good serious with
you like what what like it's a
never-ending game so you replied to 18
people on average in the past and now
you got inspired a TV now you're doing
33 well why not 47 you know you're
posting two times a tick tock you know
all of a sudden you go to you know seven
and why not eight like judgments a
[ __ ] forever game it's a bad game
yeah I guess it's hard sometimes to deal
with the guilt from fans don't
understand you know that what we do is
just so so consuming and I mean it--when
this offers started with when she went
viral and became famous I was up till
3:00 4:00 o'clock in the morning I've
heard you talk later
Christina I have I have five to fifteen
thousand dm's and texts a day and
they're in there for people write things
like this is my last text before I take
my life if you do not help me Gary I
will take my life do you understand
what level of potential guilt yeah I
have on a daily basis idea I and and
what you have to do is put that into a
place of like you're just a human being
I'm trying the best I can and we're
trying the best you can
first of all it's [ __ ] famous cat
life like we're so lucky
no it doesn't sound weird in the same
way that if a senior went on right now
with me and was crying that they
couldn't do their prom in it that's
their life that's their life and your
life is that so I don't do that but you
have to stop judging yourself you're
doing the best you can
yeah and I mean I have said that I told
my husband that before there's only so
much I can do period period yeah hear
you and every time you beat yourself up
say oh my god Gary B let's six people
kill themselves today and I mean that
and you know and listen my hope and
dream is that 99
point nine nine nine nine percent of
them are writing you know have her yes
but do I believe that it has happened
yes I do believe it doesn't break my
[ __ ] soul yes it does but what am I
gonna do like I'm not a [ __ ] robot
[ __ ] no [ __ ] I got my own [ __ ] right
okay raise your right and that's the end
of the day what I have to tell myself I
know that I'm trying to best as I can
it's not that I don't want to because my
son is so big I want to you I just don't
have the time
Christina and if you want to spend three
hours and watch a [ __ ] Netflix show
and drink a bottle of wine with your
husband you can do that too you stop
yeah stop judging yourself please I'm
working on it I've come a long way
because boy used to eat me a lot more
more use this serendipity you know if it
wasn't I'm not doing tea with Gary B
people trying to get on this on this
show on like more real quick though how
many tik toks are you making with the
cat hundred four hundred posts love you
poor hunter post right 480 pops yes fun
so we have over a million followers now
on three different platforms Facebook
Instagram tick-tock what I'm working on
and don't know how much of my for me saw
so my husband's not work I didn't say
he's in a blue collar trade okay last
Tuesday we got orders to shut down shell
turret place in place and so he's been
home so I was like man you know he's a
majority income earner believe it or not
I don't make a million dollars a year
like everybody thinks and so we're
having to go back to the drawing board
but just something I've done a lot in my
life because I'm gonna circle back to
that in a second so you know I started
flipping in 1997 um oh my god I can't
wait to tell you that okay so anyway so
he is home and he makes a considerable
amount of money
way more than I can get with the
business government grant that just came
out or unemployed we're gonna wait I'm
way more so we're going we're definitely
have a savings account that's great we
worked really hard to build that up I
mean I there's people out there that
can't pay their next mortgage or water
bills so I'm not complaining at all
again it goes back to it being your real
life laughs you know there's somebody
watching right now me like [ __ ] that
house looks beautiful look at that
payment but but the realities you worked
in [ __ ] pieces you also work his face
off for it yeah like a lot of time the
more you make the more you have the
higher your bills are so the bills is
the key though yeah like that that's
something that I passion for this is
what you have to sit down and really
look at the bills and really debate
bills you have to debate bills like you
know like you got a lot of like people
buy stuff like by the way you can flip
half your house you know every human
being whether they have one little
[ __ ] - sigh - paintings in her house
or a lot of stuff in their house every
human being hates half the stuff that's
in her house already now anyway yeah but
I mean and that's how I started flipping
but my idea was I was gonna tell you
many of you back to the flipping is that
um I've had to think what can I have him
do here I mean he's here we have nothing
but time I just told you I have a
million over million followers on three
different platforms for Venus I have
grossly neglected her YouTube channel
now for four years it's terrible
but don't be embarrassed no time if I
only I have kids you [ __ ] have a life
every single person that's watching
right now is like Jesus Christ if I had
a 10,000 followers that ripped my arm
off you're crushing it with him - so I
mean I'm just I'm wearing so many
different hats is just stretched so thin
and I need your phone oh you're home now
you have nothing but time maybe looks
too good
oh whatever yes I'm going to assign him
to the YouTube channel
he's game for it and I'll bet I have
that channel and hope that not only can
we supplement the income he's not making
right now and hopefully not have to
drain our savings but when everything
goes back to normal we'll be in a better
position
we were before because yes okay by the
way do you know that Facebook is like
Facebook ad revenue is exploding so I
would also very much focus on Facebook
as well and there's I'm in the beta that
there's a new Facebook live ad product
coming they're just always gonna be
opportunities you just keep looking and
you know since going back to the
flipping about this Christina what about
direct messaging every single cat brand
on earth cat food cat toys like all of
them
I definitely that's one thing I've been
blessed again because Venus is so unique
looking I haven't had a lot of trouble
most of it the sponsor put aside you
their incoming I don't really look for
much okay but here's the thing here's
the thing though again not having I
don't have to I have to try to find
balance I could make a whole lot more
money right now in fact I probably could
it be a millionaire if I wanted to cart
my cat all over the place if I wanted to
do commercials and movies and I music if
I got it and down last year and stuff
but I first of all have my limits with
her then I have my limits with family
because I don't want to take too much
time away from them that is what's
important to me honestly didn't making a
million dollars with my cat good me
everything I've just heard I'm so not
[ __ ] worried about you like your
mindset was so on point like you'll sell
this [ __ ] home and live in a
different home if you have to before you
compromise the things that are important
to you listen to me stop beating stop
beating yourself up your Jelena Kristina
stop beating yourself up you're a
[ __ ] superhero period please
everybody can do more and everybody can
do less and this is why I wanted to
mention the flipping I don't know how
much time I have but it's like last
seconds okay 90 97 quit I had my first
son in 1997 he got very sick with RSV he
was in the hospital a couple times I had
to stop working my day job so um I have
been an avid garage sale junkie like you
forever right so I used to buy a lot of
stuff for my son when he was born from
garage sales so I would have garage
ceiling hit a garage sale it was
multi-family a bunch of girl clothes I
only have boys I have three boys now
never had the girl but something hit me
that day that I was buying clothes off
of ebay
mrs. night 1997 right why can't I sell
so I bought everything they had for $1
apiece Gymboree Ralph Lauren Tommy
Hilfiger you know gap all the stuff that
was popular my Cheerios it snatched all
up put it on eBay I got a little system
going where you know I mean back then
we're talking regular camera--
developing the film I remember and
take-out oh my god I know it's so easy
now it makes me crazy like they used to
take me an hour each agency and then
digital camera AJ had to take the
[ __ ] disk out put it [ __ ] computer
it was a [ __ ] mess and even before I
even have a phone no digital camera
nothing it was all done in film in 97
and it was all dial-up and you did copy
to HTML and just changed a little
description oh yeah but you know what
I'm gonna tell you though I made between
one and two thousand dollars a month
back in 1997 more than replace the job
that I left and that was home with my
kid and so and I didn't realize it was
an entrepreneur until then that was my
student Christina you may be the least
you might be the person I'm at least
worried about on earth I don't wanna I
don't want to talk to you anymore oh my
god I love you so good he's doing here
wine and traveling loves Christina as
much as I did
there we go Scotty
it's unless let's get some lets follow
so I see was just on right now boom
right please
everybody's watching right now please
take a photo of this talk with Tanya and
share it on Twitter with a link to
Facebook which is in my Twitter profile
and I will weekly and follow a bunch of
you Tanya how are you hi Gary
I'm freaking out that even talking to
you right now not even gonna lie well
I'm glad we're here so I'm a
social-media influencer slash blogger
whatever you want to call it I've been
doing this before was even a thing
and obviously this pandemic has hit
everyone in so many different ways which
is kind of earth-shattering for a lot of
us I just want to know what do you think
this pandemic is gonna do to social
media marketing for businesses and
people like me explode it because most
businesses now realize they have to
become digital and sell through the
internet right I've now now now there's
also a looming potential recession so
great brand deals may get split in half
and and this is why I've been yelling
and screaming as you know about like hey
save your money
you know like be be create other
opportunities besides just brand deals
just being an influencer is
1-dimensional you got to round that out
with products services business things
that nature so in the macro Tanya great
because more people are gonna look at
digital and ways to win and digital in
the micro specifically for influencers
there could be a drying up season for
brand deals which a lot of people rely
on right yeah I mean I think a lot of us
you know I said in my form that I sent
over that I'm at the point now in my
career where brands just come to me and
it's almost like one of those things you
just get used to and you can bring it
not on purpose
you know you just it just becomes your
like you norm it's what you think
exactly and then it kind of brought the
hustle in me again to we're creating
organic content because I have all this
time now and reaching out to brands and
pitching them and where are you here you
want where you want to talk I just
started take time
big deal this is why I'm so pumped you
have to win tick-tock it's gonna be the
next platform you're gonna lose anything
like you have to go hard you have to go
back to straight humility
nobody quote/unquote knows you and
[ __ ] go hard post on tick-tock hit
the share put in your Instagram story
build that back up so your audience
knows you're there make one main feed
and be like I'm not [ __ ] going hard
like you need to go I know I've been
trying to go and see talk it's
definitely a different platform and I
feel like but you could still do you you
you could still be you and Instagram was
a different platform to the people that
were winning on Facebook pages and
Facebook pages was a different platform
it's always a different platform and
though and the way that you were like
laughing and everybody for not
understanding Instagram is how they're
laughing at you for not understand
tik-tok you know like yep you have to go
and by the way it's not it's kids for 40
seconds it's already much older than it
was even six months ago or a year ago I
I don't dance I don't do that [ __ ] I put
out my content put out your content yeah
that's true I just need to hustle on
there I just need a worker yeah [ __ ]
yeah you've got to get out of that
entitled mindset because you had one in
a prior game to your point where she
came easy right and you need to go back
to early you hustle yeah I mean it's
brought out so many different aspects of
that hustle mode and it's good it's my
way because I feel like if I don't see
something positive out of what's going
on
I mean how much positive there's gonna
be stop watching the news and reading
Facebook like this is unlimited
positivity for most people reconnecting
with old friends that you know spending
more time with family getting back to
you know you're gonna tighten up now I
like working out you know you know all
the all the brands coming to you let you
get a little flabby that's a good way
yeah that's true that's true
oh and by the way it's unlikely that you
would have taken to cuck seriously if
this if nothing had happened and then in
three years and when Instagram organic
reach collapses in three and a half
years and goes to zero like Facebook
pages you'll stop getting deals because
you can't reach anybody and it's all
happening on tick-tock and you would
have been like
no Lester I didn't think of that about
that all my friends are on sick talk and
killing it they're like you need to get
on it and I'm like I'm just
uncomfortable but I feel like the best
things come out of being uncomfortable
in certain situations like this get out
of high school mindset and just make
yeah I'm comfortable Oh what what you
know the [ __ ] you're doing makeup
backing in make an int make a tick-tock
that looks exactly like you would do on
Instagram but then learn tick-tock the
little sticker or the little colors like
play spend - are you spending time
consuming tick tock you have a feel of
the vibe or not yet yeah I'm consuming
it I think I'm consuming him more way
more than I am producing good I'm gonna
get fired and think of other ideas and
stop overthinking it yeah it's not it's
not some new cooler Club and you were
like the cool chick and that's one club
and now there's a new club it's not a
it's not that it's just I mean no [ __ ]
that's why I'm telling my a little bit
because I have a seventh month old and
getting baby cons that just does good in
general people people love babies and
I've been trying to put him into it so
this would be babies advice random [ __ ]
get inspired and use something dorky
just [ __ ] live but yes our [ __ ]
make it four tick tock now all right I'm
gonna do it
take care
all right Bobby blackjack Mamere Bobby
blackjack good news bro under three
hundred eighty-eight follower
also a guaranteed we're gonna do a
guaranteed follow on Twitter blitz right
now if you sign up for why text my dad's
platform wine text calm right now and
post the screen of you joining I will
follow you let's keep going
Dean hey Gary how you doing I'm doing
super well bro how are you you know what
I'm doing quite peachy yeah taking the
time so I guess we'll jump into it so my
question for you was at what point or
maybe you never do it do you start
divesting or diverging from your brand
yourself your persona and start focusing
on content for your businesses so
something that I've noticed is that
people do better in the social media
marketing realm content delivery then
businesses talking uh they do better in
engagement in building audiences don't
forget it's social media its
peer-to-peer pre-book uh but they don't
necessarily do better in business
results okay so for example being very
effective on LinkedIn as a b2b business
right now you can annihilate revenue in
comparison to an influencer who has four
million followers so I would I better in
the metrics that we all see likes
followers engagement but not better in
actual business results if you look
under the hood okay because brand brands
that put out organic content jabs who
then come in with a sales pitch a right
hook if they do it extremely well crush
in business results a lot of people are
really good at jabbing and are bad at
right hooks a lot of people are over
write hooky and you know so you know a
lot of people have a lot of followers
because they're attractive because
they're funny but you know but doesn't
really lead to business results right so
there's a little bit of that dynamic
theme to keep in mind okay yeah because
I've been so I originally a so I have a
full-time job in sales and then I have
my own personal brand basically built up
just around high performance and healthy
living and different just motivational
tips right I'm not trying to be a life
coach or anything like that I got it
enjoying it yeah yeah I just been you
know
and is there as there are and then
there's the and if this leads to people
being aware of me of what I do
professionally that's a nice thing yeah
exactly
do you in your personal brand profile do
you link to something that shows your
professional part of your life so that's
the thing so I have a website that takes
you to my own personal and then it shows
something like I have a podcast and I'm
starting and I have you know takes you
to that but then what's your biggest
profile huh what's your biggest profile
your personal brand what's that so
that's Dean Stavros calm and I'm face
but what about unsocial so is it
Facebook Instagram LinkedIn I'm what's
your Instagram name Dean Stavro sta vro
you is it at real Dean Strabo yeah
that's it okay so you know excuse me I
was looking at I was looking at Twitter
I'm on there so I'm on all the platforms
on Instagram it's Dean Starbuck yeah
yeah we give it one second I just want
to see something
and then it goes to your website the
link and that goes here sign up for a
free newsletter and what do you want to
have happen with the free newsletter so
I was doing I was gonna do a newsletter
and I'm actually revising it right now
I'm gonna start a podcast instead an
interview tional podcast to talk and
what's the long term hope on that do you
hope to be hired to consult businesses
so yeah so my other businesses so the
other the other businesses that I have
so I work for a company and I do sales
consulting technical sales consulting
for large scale companies and then at
the same time in a previous life and
some time restarting is small business
technology consulting helping business
make sense of that we also my wife stay
right there
i Paulo me finish that thought she also
started a fast-casual brand that we were
watching here in Nashville and well now
this happened so we're kind of pivoting
into deliveries but anyway so we have
all the stuff going on and is it very
number numbered ye yes you and number
two is the key I want you to put out all
your best advice for free about what
small businesses should be thinking
about from a tax standpoint literally
literally all your best advice literally
make it feel like hey hey Rick hey Sasha
hey Susan I'm gonna put out content that
allows you not to hire me mm-hmm and if
you do that if you code from that lens
I'm gonna put out such good content so
detailed in video form that people are
not gonna hire me you will be stunned by
how many people hire you yeah okay got
it
yeah I appreciate it you gotta put that
that is the breakthrough that's where
nobody gets it
yeah that's what I do watch what I do
not what I say I'm giving out my best
[ __ ] advice for free yep yes you are
and vaynermedia is the biggest fastest
growing agency in marketing you know
what I mean that's true so that got it
got it all right brother totally sure
you got it
I can tell Dean got it I love that he
[ __ ] did get it all right see houses
in here sign up for my text you got
Tania thank you for doing that boom
there's Jennifer Thompson Jennifer
you're gonna be blown away today $46.00
Pinot Noir coming to you for under 20
bucks a bottle it's [ __ ] crazy Dan
Jordan what's good how are you real well
what are you from bro I am from Denver
Colorado it's a pleasure what can I help
you with well first off I just want to
thank you for all you do
found your content a few years ago and
it's really helped just set my life off
and a lot of folks I know as well so
thank you thank you of course so my goal
overall is to help people and just how
people set their businesses on fire
that's why what I do but for me to be in
integrity with myself I had to create my
own business because I believe in doing
what I tell people to do right
absolutely
I'm a big fan of that it's very much
been the foundation of why I think I've
been able to pop it's cuz I actually did
something I didn't just start off being
somebody worth listening to
I did it and then I started talking keep
going appreciate that
so I started through reselling of
auction items and eBay dropshipping and
I also want to say that I blame and
thank you for the way that I troll
Facebook and Craigslist that was best
damn what's your best flip o'clock I
found like a no no not a grandmother
clock but a small clock I got it for
like 30 bucks sorta for 150 so far
oh man it's awesome I love it so thank
you I'm also I was in the process of
moving into Amazon wholesale and FBA all
of that but I'm also a trainer and I
developed a course for networking to
teach people how to network where
they're serving and not asking I
recently just moved to Colorado uprooted
my entire life to do it because again
when I tell people to don't live your
life I have to do it myself
first right so I've done that but my
resources are low my job is gone my
checks my last couple of checks didn't
come in and I feel stuck
I have the up I see the opportunities
there ton everywhere
but I have a small amount of capital
that I need the bang for the buck
essentially right so I'm in a place
where the lips like I push my glass when
you feel stuck what do you do you you
[ __ ] [ __ ] attack on all fronts you
know when you feel stuff you know
selling the class doing the flipping
finding stuff on Facebook marketplace if
you're super scared of cologne a mask
and gloves go and pick it up then take
it home take the photo repost it make
the arbitrage on that like you know what
a lot of Americans have never felt is
running out of options like they've
never really had their back to the
corner a lot of people got laid off that
never got laid off in their lives you
know a lot of people didn't save a lot
of people just got caught and that's
real life now the good news is look this
doesn't look like it's gonna be the
Great Depression or 1987 or 9/11 or you
know or even the Great Recession like
this does have light at the end of the
tunnel people are gonna have to be
really clamping down for the next three
six nine months and and so really this
goes down to like cooking for yourself
with lower-cost ingredients eating bad
food potentially even though United said
stuff this goes into like buying nothing
buy nothing this goes into looking a
credit card
oh [ __ ] I'm signed up for Hulu Netflix
and Amazon Prime let me put you know
like this is like you know offense on
the flipping and the course but but
great defense this is time to be the 85
Bears you need to look at the [ __ ]
like every [ __ ] penny that comes out
of your world you need to tighten up and
even are you renting right now I am and
I've actually about listened to a lot of
what you did that's how I got out here
but I used a lot of resources to get out
here and I respect that
listen plenty people got caught with
timing they just bought the building
they just bought an apartment they just
started the business you know life has
twists and turns right um the reality is
it's like you just got a bunker down for
nine months here mentally and I think
everybody if they just really focus on
expenses
you know even if they get kicked out of
their apartment and you live in a [ __ ]
shitty plague living in a [ __ ] you
know shitty place for four months like
that's real talk
that's real life offensive defense just
please make sure you look at every
single dollar that comes out of your
world and audit the [ __ ] out of it bear
can do appreciate it brother
wish you well thank you alright
everybody thank you so much for another
episode of tea with Gary Vee I thought
we had a ton of good stuff today I hope
it brought you value I hope you've got
some insights from it and most of all I
hope you've passed it on to friends and
family and and then for everybody who
saw it we did sign up for wine text it's
coming out in an hour if you if you love
Pinot Noir $46.00 Pinot for $19 and
change it's [ __ ] crazy juice so I'm
super pumped about that and and I'll see
everybody tomorrow gotta go into
meetings CSCS yet see ya Thank You
Dustin on the ones and twos Thank You
team Gary for Jake said I know everybody
else has held up the phones to Instagram
and Twitter hopefully got your stands
from Amazon already Shane good there big
shout out to the reddit community love
having you guys a part of this again
today and and two and two nine three one
five seven three one if you want to get
on the show you want to get on tea with
Gary B two one two nine three one five
seven three one text in your question
we'll see you tomorrow 9:00 a.m. Eastern
with tea with Gary Vee see
your phones